let's talk about aliens
we already mentioned it
let's start just by with the basic
what's your intuition as of today this
is a thing that could change day by day
but how many alien civilizations out
there is it zero
is it
a handful is it almost endless like the
the
the you know the observable universe or
the universe is teeming with life
if i had gun to my head i have to take a
guess
i would say it's teaming with life i
would say there is i think uh running a
monte carlo simulation this paper by
ander sandberg and drexler and a few
others um a couple years ago i think you
probably know about it
i think they're they're
the
mean
um
you know using different
uh
using different you know running through
randomized rake equation
multiplication
you ended up with 27 million as the mean
in of intelligent civilizations in the
galaxy in the milky way alone
um and so then if you go outside the
milky way that would turn into trillions
that's the that's the mean now what's
interesting is that there's a long tail
because they believe some of these
multipliers in the drake equation so for
example the pers the
probability that life
starts in the first place
they think that the uh the kind of range
that we use
is for that variable or is way too small
and that's constraining our
possibilities and if you actually extend
it to you know you know some some crazy
number of orders of magnitude like 200
they think should that that variable
should be uh
you get this long tail where
i forget the exact number but it's like
a third or a quarter of the total
outcomes have us alone like so you know
i think it's like i think it's a sizable
percentage has us as the only
intelligent
life in the galaxy but you can keep
going and i think there's like you know
a non-zero like legitimate amount of
outcomes there that have us as the only
life in the observable universe at all
is on earth i mean it seems incredibly
counter-intuitive it seems like you know
you mentioned that people think um
you're you know you must be an idiot
because um you know if you picked up one
grain of sand on a beach and examined it
and you found all these little things on
it
it's like saying well maybe this is the
only one that has that and it's like
probably not they're probably uh most of
the sand probably hear a lot of the sand
right
so and then the other hand we don't see
anything we don't see any evidence you
know which of course people would say
that the people who
scoff at the concept that we're
potentially alone
um they say well of course there's lots
of reasons we wouldn't have seen
anything and and they can go list them
and they're very compelling but
we don't know and the truth is if there
were if this were a freak thing i mean
we don't if this were a completely freak
thing that happened here whether it's
life at all or just getting to this
level intelligence
that species whoever it was would think
there must be lots of us out there and
they'd be wrong so
just being again using the same
intuition that most people would use i'd
say there's probably lots of other
things out there yeah and you wrote a
great blog post about it but to me the
two interesting
reasons
that we haven't been in contact i i too
have an intuition that the universe is
teaming with life
so one interesting is around the great
filter
so we're either the grade filters either
behind us or in front of us so
the the reason that's interesting is you
get to think about what kind of things
ensure or um
ensure the survival of an intelligent
civilization or lead to the destruction
of intelligent civilization that's a
very pragmatic very important question
to always be asking and we'll talk about
some of those and then
the other one is
i'm saddened by the possibility that
there could be aliens communicate with
us all the time in fact they may have
visited
and we're just too dumb
to hear it to see it like the
um
the idea that the kind of life that can
evolve
is just the range of life that can
evolve is so large
that our narrow view of what is life
and what is intelligent life is
preventing us from having communication
with them but that then they don't seem
very smart because if they were trying
to communicate with us they would surely
if they were super intelligent they
would be very i'm sure if there's lots
of life we're not that rare we're not
some crazy weird species that hears and
you know has different kinds of ways of
of
perceiving signals so they would
probably be able to see you know if you
really wanted to communicate with an
earth-like species
with a human-like species um you would
send out all kinds of things you'd send
out you know radio
radio waves and and you send out gravity
waves and and
lots of things so if they're
communicating in a way they're trying to
communicate with us and it's just we're
too dumb to perceive the signals it's
like well they're not doing a great job
of uh considering the primitive
species we might be so i i don't know i
think i think if a super intelligent
species wanted to get in touch with us
um
uh and had the capability of i think
probably
they would
well that
they may be getting in touch with us
they're just getting in touch with the
thing that we humans are not
understanding that they're getting in
touch with us with that i guess that's
what i was trying to say is
there could be something about earth
that's much more special than us humans
like the nature of the intelligence
that's on earth
or
the thing that's of value and that's
curious and that's complicated and
fascinating and beautiful
might be something that's not just like
uh tweets
okay like english language that's
interpretable or any kind of language or
any kind of signal whether it's uh
gravity or radio signal that humans seem
to appreciate
what why not the actual
it could be the process of evolution
itself there could be something about
the way that earth is breathing
essentially through the creation of life
and this
complex growth of light there's like
it's a whole different way to view
organisms and view life that could be
getting communicated with and we humans
are just a tiny fingertip on top of that
intelligence and the communication is
happening with
with the main mothership
of earth versus us humans that seem to
treat ourselves as super important
and we're missing the big picture i mean
it sounds crazy but
our understanding of what is intelligent
of what is life what is consciousness is
very limited and it seems to be
and just being very suspicious it seems
to be awfully human-centric
you